so you see I mean I'm trying to go for
the house and you're saying Matt listen
you want a million subscribers will you
put out any good con I want a couple
hundred thousand subscribers look I'll
go with good [ __ ] luck I bet I don't
know how to [ __ ] do that I'm not your
best car first you do that you do the
reviews you do every five days you do a
review okay let that mediocre [ __ ] and
see if it gets you a hundred thousand
subscribers what about that great idea
that I had for that show
I just say you and GQ and and Vanity
Fair doing it right now
Larry lot and got six point nine million
views in less than a year and he did for
it was twenty minutes can we talk about
your vanity fair deal I talked to them I
did a little thing that is gonna be the
cover of Vanity Fair not gonna be on
that's not what happened people do tell
us what the truth is what's the truth
about man they talk to me you're gonna
do an article on you know then what they
want to do a Syria video series with
them Larry Laden thing where I do four
or five con man movies then I review
them and I said you that's what we ought
to do I don't see what they're doing a
series they do one what is so
frustrating being on here Danny you know
a DD but and then now you're here and
this guy this guy's there one thing
hasn't said one thing to help it's
nothing but he's not here to [ __ ] I'm
here to help I'm here to encourage oh my
god so yeah there they have I guess you
could call a series but they get like
they'll get Larry Lawton and he'll do
he'll review some heist movies then they
get some FBI guy to do some FBI movies
mmm and they were gonna have me do some
conman movies but that's cool they used
they were like first they wanted to do
it Skype and I was like really you
really want to do it Skype I mean that
you know they're like well you know in
the current situation like it's kind of
[ __ ] up it's half-assed
I was like but I said look I said what
if I got somebody was gonna have you I
said what if I could get you somebody
that could do it
and they said yeah let me let me think
about that let me get back with you what
I haven't heard from a business okay hmm
so hope
I really hope that it happens I think
that would be great I mean it would be
one thing I'm saying do a whole
nevermind it's over so Alyssa I got this
I got I what just listen you guys bicker
it really is I mean are you ready for
the next question
question we got Jermaine Wells if you
didn't get into real estate did you have
any other career dreams you wanted to
pursue and he also wants to know
additionally since we're watching live
would you take any special orders on
your book during this time and add a
signature or a doodle on the cover
honestly I've had a I have at least one
guy a one or two a guy's really a week
mail me their books I sign them like if
you included if you include a piece of
paper I tell me like you want a certain
sit like I'll put like you know to John
you know I'll put my favorite partner in
crime you know from Matt Cox the secret
services most one and then I send it
back to him some of the guys look at 90
percent of guys don't even give me like
a return envelope I'm paying I had a guy
from from Canada I paid $20 to ship his
book back to Canada damn man you know
which I don't I mean I care because to
be honest it's it's you know it's
flattering to have somebody want you to
sign the book so if I have you know I
don't want to take a hit that was that
was a hit yes that's it um but you know
I couldn't be doing that all the time
normally I mail it back cuz you mail it
back and even if you break even it
doesn't matter it's it's so male your
book to man yeah I'll send the return
postage in there don't be a cheapskate
that you'll sign it say hey do it I'll
do just giving your address out or I got
a peel bar you're so [ __ ] everything
okay which so it's no crab good I'm
gonna get to snow crab I'll take I'm
gonna get to peace I'm gonna get to snow
crab trays do you have a snow crab pizza
we can get a lot of snow crab Palmer's
now blue crab blue crowd know the
difference right now yes snow crab
blue crab no crab yeah we're delivered
he's a big shot the crispy crab crispy
crab is a gas it is fire
yeah they got boiled peanuts you guys
want some boiled peanuts I love in
garlic sauce oh do I love I was gonna
get some earlier are you I'm gonna get
sausage listen I'm playing cause I don't
like the hot oh my sweat the plain just
tastes like good old water here's the
sinuses this guy says you hurt Danny's
feelings all right ready for rolling
another question yes d listen Steve is
the guy that owns a production company
that I've been talking to that wants to
do that wants to do all the reviews the
movie reviews your idea just now that
you just came up with it's a great idea
I hope somebody runs with it absolutely
I think so and we've already talked to a
we already talked to you know what is
her name
because I always say her name wrong
Karolina but bazoo yeah so anyway yes
she's gonna set up the production
everything that's a great idea I think I
mean that's the hard part with anything
is just getting started and getting over
that initial step of not feeling like
it's good enough
still we got two plates of crab on the
way I feel like I need to books in
getting everything in you know in order
you go you do it you put it and then
I'll put it on my channel that's what I
plan on doing hopefully in a month from
now I start having content on my channel
and I'm gonna have it on there for six
months and I'm gonna have about 150 200
thousand subscribers and then I'm gonna
do a true-crime podcast but then you're
gonna go then you're gonna be like go
man oh man everybody subscribe this
listening right now exists inside
true-crime on YouTube even if
you have will drop it again even if
we're gonna drop the link in the chat
right now so you can go subscribe to
Matt Cox I look bad there even if you
have to I didn't to remove your
subscription from from concrete
yeah just unsubscribe and move it to to
to inside true crime I curse reasonable
Danny won't be offended we got ten
pounds what is that equal in American
money ten pounds yeah Matt come on you
got to know this a pound like I'm buying
it alright I sound confident
let's do everybody's dollar sixty-five
between ten twenty bucks what the show
idea yeah yeah because here's the thing
to like let's say let's say I review
boiler room you know how many guys I
know that ran boiler rooms like I know
that's not how it works or that is how
it work look I know guys that ran Ponzi
schemes not one or two
I know multiple Ponzi scheme guys they
have great stories horrible stories I
mean they've they've destroyed people
but the point is they some of the
stories are interesting especially how
they get into it they never they never
it's always something goes wrong and it
evolves coz if you if you get into a
Ponzi scheme like if you said hey I want
to start up I'm gonna do a Ponzi scheme
if you knew from the get-go
I'm gonna start a Ponzi scheme and this
is a scam yeah it's so easy to setup a
Ponzi scheme that isn't in your name you
set up a fake identity you dump a bunch
of money into a decent website some
brochures you do a little bit of
advertising you do a couple of events
people start giving you money they don't
expect the money back you keep telling
them their money's growing periodically
you give them dividends they usually
typically say oh just keep reinvesting
it before you know it you've got ten
fifteen twenty million dollars and then
if you were to disappear they don't ever
know who you were to begin with problem
is most Ponzi schemes start off
legitimate and they morphs into a Monsey
scheme and the next thing you know
they're trying to balance this Ponzi
scheme of a hundred million dollars and
they're like I'm [ __ ] over my head
what went wrong well what went wrong was
when things went bad you should have
just been honest with your investors and
taken the hit
yeah you know given them but what you
could back and file bankruptcy now you
got a hundred million dollar Ponzi
scheme you're going to prison the rest
of your life yeah so but yeah great to
do you do all kinds of different movies
and I know most guys that have run those
types of schemes mm-hmm people just want
to hear you talk I mean you can
interview anybody and they would [ __ ]
buy the guy that could watch [ __ ] stop
yeah people like to hear people honestly
they just like to hear somebody who can
speak concisely and confidently and
notice listened to you all day not
really I'm like a babbling idiot
um yeah I'm [ __ ] a babble I don't
[ __ ] talk I stutter I don't know what
I'm talking about
I don't speak as charismatic Li and
confidently as you do no Matt Cox you're
a good storyteller yeah you're a very
good store now you switched it earlier
it was back down he's feeling good about
himself yank the carpet out from
underneath all right let's do the next
one
next question yeah all right we got a
real underscore Joe Biden damn thanks
Joe the most flagrant weaknesses that
exist in secured lending including
mortgages today what are you paying
attention I am but you didn't read all
that great what are the most highest
lady grant I could tell what he was
talking to me as I started watering it
all right what are the most flagrant
weaknesses that exist in secured lending
including mortgages today I mean I would
say it's funny I actually talked to a
guy who I went to the title company
spoke with a guy that's starting a
company that he's he owns a title
company he's starting a separate company
that monitors people's titles because
it's becoming rampant real estate with
people removing people's deeds on their
homes and putting them into other
people's names so he were talking about
what I had done and he was
Oh what you did back then is easier to
do now
he said now public records you don't
even have to have the original document
you can make a copy of the document and
put a stamp on it it says that true that
you witnessed the true and corrected
true incorrect a actual document like oh
I've seen the real document file this
one it's not even an original document
don't have to have an original seal
don't have to have anything just a stamp
on it that oh I saw the original this is
and so this is good they'll record it he
was telling me all kinds of little
things I was like are you [ __ ]
serious
and he goes yeah he goes it's easier now
to do what you did than it was back then
I have all these guys in the comments
saying you can't do that anymore
really the guy that owns a title come
and he's telling me it's easier now so
it's still it's still public records
public records is just a it's just right
for fraud I mean it's just it's a it's a
huge gaping hole but what's nice is most
people don't understand how public
records works and so they don't take
advantage they don't commit fraud you
just using public records because they
don't really understand how it works so
if you're an if you're someone who
worked at a title company or you have
any any experience in that and you say
look I'm gonna go ahead and use this to
my advantage I mean it's it's a huge
opportunity for it's a huge issue as far
as frauds concerned but there's such a
limited amount of people that can do it
so and then of course if you have
overlapping skill sets it gets it gets
outrageous and I'd say that's still the
the main problem with real estate is
public records you can say oh you can
make w2's but yeah but that's been done
and they people do it they're always
gonna do it and it's virtually
impossible to catch it and stop it so
the one thing that's a huge I don't want
to use the word opportunity a huge issue
is public records that's the problem
public records if you could secure a
problem to all the records but keep mine
to the left hand doesn't know what the
Rights doing right and the government
and then when things go wrong it's not a
big enough problem that there's no
reason really to stop it and it doesn't
cost the government a more anything
because when it all goes wrong it's the
title companies that have to pay so it's
kind of you know the government's
insulated from it so there's no
reason to try and revamp this system why
would we revamp a system it doesn't cost
us anything and when it does cost
anybody it cost the banks the banks all
have insurance or there was real estate
or there was title insurance so it's
kind of it you know just like it's like
the credit card companies most of them
didn't want to replace the credit cards
with chips for a decade they fought
because their whole thing is yeah but
the fraud is already built into the
interest rate so we've already got this
money set aside so it's not really
hurting us it's hurting the customers
really it's not really hurting us yeah
so why would we correct it until
eventually the government said no you're
gonna do the chip and they forced them
to do the chip is this chip any more
secure no not really cuz I before they
even came out John Murr jambo dziak the
guy at the credit card kid I wrote that
story mm-hmm called it's called bent and
he was manufacturing credit cards for
the Russian mob great story bro this
guy's amazing
super smart now haven't seen him now I
mean he's covered in tattoos oh god he's
got TAC yeah everywhere he looks like a
straight gangster and but really when he
was in prison he had like a tattoo here
and someone is and his arms and stuff
but he's 135 pounds like Justin Bieber
how old was he when you met him in
prison 29 or 30 that's crazy and so now
it's been five years and if you go to
his Instagram account he's just covered
in tats he just does tats just add it up
but he was saying before the chips in
the US even came out they had already
cloned them and even have you ever gone
have you ever gone to the store and you
put your card in and the chip won't work
and they could just slide it yeah okay
so we're back to the old [ __ ] that's
easier okay so what does it matter what
are we doing yeah what's the worst case
scenario they say can I see your ID
you think if I can man if I can make oh
yeah we're good yeah go ahead and take
your Rolex watch and leave thank you I
mean this is not securing it just add an
extra layer which nobody's paying
attention to